stranger things big bad wekner has
joined the ranks of tv and films great
iconic horror villains but as scary as
he already is there were a ton of even
more terrifying designs and looks that
didn't make the final cut yupi kai movie
lovers i'm jan and in this video i'm
revealing and explaining all the
horrifying bechner designs you never got
to see in the show this early version of
vetena had an armored shell over his
body and face and was inspired by the
prehistoric fish the dunkleosteus this
giant fish which was up to 29 feet long
and could weigh over four tons had large
bony plates that formed its face and
jaws and like wechner was a fearsome
predator the idea behind this original
design was that over time living in the
upside down had hardened and separated
pieces of henry's skin from each other
forming these tough plates over his body
another iteration of this design used a
spiky version of the armor which almost
gives them the appearance of being
covered in shards of rock or stone the
designs ended up being rejected as they
were too rigid and didn't allow for
enough of vectors expressions and
emotions to come through
this next early design had some
grotesque insect-like arms and legs the
look was inspired by the real-life
mantis and its two large four legs which
have adapted so that the creature can
catch and grab its prey the arms of this
particular vector could also split open
to form claws that he would then use to
stab his victims something vechna
actually did in his final form but with
his more human-like claws it's a very
creepy design that would have fit well
with henry creel's love of spiders and
it also reminds me of pennywise's spider
form in it chapter 2. the issue with it
though was that it would have been very
hard to achieve practically given the
extended appendages needed for the
villain the duffer brothers were keen
that that can have a practical feel
about him and the final version of the
villain was all practical makeup and
prosthetics with just vfx used for his
vines
this alternate version of wekner is much
more alien-like with some kind of skin
or webbing growing over and covering his
eyes making him appear almost blind the
thinking behind this look was to give
wekner more of an extraterrestrial vibe
with the idea being that henry's time in
the upside down had transformed him into
something closer to a demogorgon than a
human according to the artist michael
maher jr his look also reminds me of the
pale manned villain from pan's labyrinth
who eats children akin to wekner who
targets teenagers in season four
another early idea for wekner's look was
to have a patchwork of skin stretched
over his gaunt body the idea was
inspired by hellraiser and i think what
they were going for was the antagonist
frank who comes back from the dead in a
degenerated state until his body begins
to grow back flesh and skin as he
consumes his victims
an even more gruesome version of this
idea gave wekner extra pale skin like a
vampire which seems fitting given the
introduction of the demo bats in season
four and his teeth and mouth in this
design gives me some real cellobite
chatter revives from the hellraiser
franchise and there's a touch of the
demon of the mind elegos from ash vs the
evil dead in this design too these
designs were inspired by the idea that
because henry had been living in the
upside down for so long his skin had
begun to rot away falling apart in
patches with him clamping the skin
together to save it in an extra gross
version the skin hung over vacna's jaw
and in another the skin had melted over
his eyes and in this design whenever
wekner used his powers his eyes would
cry blood similar to what we see happens
to vacuna's victims the multiple eyes in
this design also remind me of henry and
his love of spiders creatures which
typically have many eyes all these
designs were rejected because similar to
the problem with wekner's armored skin
they didn't allow for enough expression
another idea that was initially explored
was for henry to become infected with a
type of gangrene that would corrupt his
body the thinking was that after years
of living in the upside down a mouldy
type of rot together with vines had
taken hold of henry's body and the
artist describes it as a type of
tumorous gangrene that would eat away at
wekner's flesh these designs followed a
similar idea the difference being that
the rot on wechner's body was a bit
brighter coloured and was a type of
radioactive rot that henry had caught
from his exposure to the upside down
although these looks were suitably scary
for the villain the designs were
discarded because they didn't disguise
wekner's true identity this was crucial
so that it would be more difficult to
immediately realize that the seemingly
friendly orderly that eleven first meets
at hawkins lab is actually the series
big bad
this alternate design for vechna
emphasizes his asymmetrical look with
his oversized left arm but with also a
giant tentacle attached a particularly
weird unused design is this one where
vacna still had some thin long strands
of hair on his head an idea that was
quickly rejected in all the subsequent
designs this vector also has some little
spikes growing out of his shoulders and
hands and the look of his face reminds
me a little of the serial killer from
the movie smiley i think it's safe to
say that most of these alternate designs
for vechna are even more terrifying and
unsettling than the already scary
version of the villain we did get in the
end the more humanoid version they went
for reflects his human origins better
together with the elements of the upside
down that became part of his body such
as roots vines and new muscle tissue
veteran has red purple and black colors
which are associated with the upside
down are meant to show how the alternate
dimension took over his body and any
human flesh left over is pale because
he's been away from daylight for such a
long time i do want to thank emmy
nominated artist michael marr junior for
sharing all of these incredible and
original designs for wekner which barry
gower and his makeup effects company
translated into an amazing on-screen
look for the villain the prosthetic
makeup took between six and seven hours
every day to apply meaning that the
makeup team and actor jamie campbell
bowers working day began at two or three
am so he'd be ready for shooting later
that morning and it then took another
hour once filming was finished each day
to take it all off all in all henry juan
and veckner make an incredibly
compelling central villain in stranger
things and if you'd like to learn how i
expect the series to end tap here to
watch my season 5 theory video and also
why 11 will end up using time travel to
defeat wekner there's also links in the
video description so movie lovers what
do you think of these alternate wekner
designs let me know in the comments
below if you liked this video do leave a
thumbs up i really appreciate it and you
can tap left to discover every
incredible easter egg you missed in the
final part of season 4. thanks for
enjoying stranger things with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie loving
week yippie kai movie lovers